the port city of bandaka our starting
point right on the equator with the Epic
Congo the focus of life here the river
is Larder bathroom and transport
hub for travel upstream and down in all
manner of craft
it's about ten to six days just staring
into action here in bandaka and we're
off up River to explore one of the oil
blocks designated for auction by the
government and should find some remote
communities
scale of the Congo is bewildering here
looking more like a vast Lake as it
meanders West to the Atlantic Ocean
we're heading two days in the opposite
direction over 400 kilometers Upstream
deep into the Congo basin
our journey is soon flanked by dense
rainforest giving way now and then to
Riverside Villages where life mostly
goes on as it has for centuries
it's a life that could be upturned by
the government's auction of oil blocks
for 27 oil blocks and three gas blocks
and
the two blocks is inside
and then that's why we are going there
to talk with communities people are
afraid about how they will they are
asking about their land they are
thinking that they will lost their land
after the Amazon the Congo Basin is the
greatest tract of rainforest on Earth
spanning six countries across central
Africa containing huge quantities of oil
that the government wants to sell off to
the highest bidder worth an estimated to
600 billion dollars
after seven hours on the water a chance
to stock up on fuel and supplies
we're a long way still from the oil
sites but I want to know what people
here think about the potential
exploration
we have not had anything from the
government our life depends on the river
we think this will cause big problems we
need an explanation
we all live in poverty if this comes it
will help us to improve our lives
divided opinion perhaps but we were to
find that sense of inequity and indeed
opposition to the blocks themselves
would grow once we got deeper into the
forest
for now we set up camp in isoko Village
as night closes in
Clark Al Jazeera Democratic Republic of
Congo